on a morning like this the why Valley is
a special place it's worth getting up
for and following a path that people
have taken for centuries out to harvest
the food that will feed Britain and help
change their lives it's a job British
workers just don't want to do no point
six percent of seasonal agricultural
workers in the UK are British naught
point 6 percent almost everyone else is
Eastern European but the lack of clarity
around brexit has sowed out in these
fields
many of the Pickers here question
whether they themselves will be the last
crop Sam nobody really was named Elina
started as a picker in these fields 8
years ago she's now the harvest manager
and they have families they need to take
care for they rely on the income from
here and if we can't provide them with
that security they are looking for they
will find somewhere else a job is that
already happening people looking
elsewhere yes it does we we've lost some
people since last year they moved in
different other countries in you they
have options but this is that preferred
destination meeting the people that I've
met you know the year before that it's
nice yeah that's yeah I hope they don't
close the doors for us to come here
moment nobody quite knows what's going
to happen yeah nobody knows and what
would you say then to the politicians in
Britain who are making those decisions I
hope they make the right decision and
let us come back to work here
while the government says nothing will
change until 2020 the Home Office still
hasn't announced whether there will be a
seasonal worker visa scheme post brexit
they're better off because they're short
and fine beam because they're because
they're little for Chris whose family
have farmed this land for generations
it's a big moment without staff we don't
harvest the crops if we can't harvest
the crops we're going to stop planting
the crops that means that business
disappears and that means those crops
disappear from the supermarket shelves
so it's pretty straightforward I think
what would you say to those people who
would accuse you of being another Ramona
well I think we're on the ground with
this you know it's not um it's not a
theoretical sort of exercise I've got a
hundred people in the field here behind
me you know at peak were employing a
thousand people I don't have massively
strong views on the EU or really mind
either way but ultimately this is one
direct impact a No Deal brexit scenario
would make things even less certain but
nobody here can do anything about it
other than get their job done
well this is the entire King day so it's
called we are waiting for them in the
priests back home today sorry they burnt
it today yeah they wondered yeah they
did a good job and this is home on the
edge of this Herefordshire farm a pop-up
Eastern European village with room for
up to seven hundred Bernie's Caravan and
she's just finished work bene emma has
recruited nearly 5000 workers for this
farm but it's getting harder we need
some clarity we need it they need it
because the people that want to come but
still want to come and work here aren't
even sure if they're allowed to so they
need some clarity they need some
certainty been a story shows you just
how much people want this and what they
give up to be here for ten months of the
year she doesn't see her kids girl and
boy and they're in Bulgaria yes
okay and they stay with your family
there yes sometimes my boy my boy no
understand he want he wants his mom but
better when we stay here for money
they don't want to stop they want to
carry on picking packing and paying tax
here they just need someone in
government to tell them that there is a
plan and it includes the people who help
feed us Tom Parmenter Sky News
Herefordshire